[Musique]
je
c'est sa voix j'aime bien savoir la
vibration de savoie
bien plus mon équipe comme le gabon le
matin mais puis gentillesse et la
douceur ou pas senti comme c'est un
membre en france hors fois au gala était
prête à tout le monde
c'était l'enfant de dieu n'était pas
aidée pour toi qui chalosse et yolande a
choisi c'est fou ça
[Musique]
qu'ils y jouent
c'était à sa part de paraître banale
parce que c'était sentiment de vide
questionnement aussi tout de suite on se
dit mais pourquoi lui attend de gens
mauvais pourquoi lui
on va peut-être même jusqu'à se remettre
en question ses croyances et puis
justement parce qu'on voit tous ces gens
parce qu'on voit toutes ces obédiences
parce qu'on voit que chacun porte et
albert a sa façon bien ça réconforte et
on se dit comme me l'ont dit d'ailleurs
certains de ses frères on va dire eh
bien qu'ils étaient en mission et sa
console un peu
[Musique]
il est 4 heures on se réveille mois d'où
deux boulettes d'or on se réveille c'est
sur radio martinique et puis nouvelle
massif est bien formation chiite après
quelque chose chaque jour par il
partageait aussi pas boiter cali et
haddad essaïdi là-bas et ussel
il fallait qu'ils racontent il fallait
qu'ils te disent qu'ils avaient lu ça il
fallait qu'ils partagent avec toi il
contient d'autres audits et lb à
l'antenne mais pas tenzin frontières et
audités albéa des eaux à l'antenne
non le gars est elle à l'antenne comme
idée il était dans la vie ouvert prête à
partager
et ça le lot parler à partager les web
mimoun mon cas ça comme amelio donc on
est obligé mais hollywood
[Musique]
albert est né donc à abu dhabi est
ensuite venu habiter alemao est venu
habiter chez toi non il est venu habiter
chez sa maman et après je les prie avec
moi le québec était venu chez toi je
croise toujours mais il parlait beaucoup
moins d'appétit il me disait à chaque
fois qu'on gère vote s'il me prépare
notre la perche salim al din hm après
elle m'a dit toute la journée de l'eau
trois périodes à fossa limite est même
un baptême est tellement nous tu as
toujours pension dans le basket
et les variations du cabinet npd ça
démarre donc baissé adp mao le groupe
aecon inc et géomatique avocats du
magistrat peut toujours nous intéresse
c'est des vacances en somme toutes les
vacances ensemble et je ne voudrais pas
aller vraiment seller mallet léon maillé
les branches et ellie et et puis après
ils étaient comme était-il antenne du
café la jam à taux de change et mais la
diorite et un grand manager radio canut
eamonn walsh a travaillé pour faire
patienter les impossibilités bien
rentabiliser sa conduite et son
application au travail
pourtant tous les mois qui m'attaquent
apporter sa boîte est content de se fier
aux médias comme c'était un enfant oui
infligées allaient même beaucoup
parmi eux la paillade yumbo radio et
elle fouille a été l'école tout joyeux 4
a failli la délivrance c'est à bailly et
flash la wii
la schl à nice et on sait mais ça
c'était c'était les vacances arrivent et
qui te l'avais dit oui
l'ailé ces machins là d'une bouée partie
coup c'est un coût pour les hauts faits
pour une partie et ça joue là ça me
rappelle toujours ce jour là parce qu'il
avait changé tout son argent dolan il
venait à la maison j'aime bien me dire
mais conforme l'ajout d'un contact sarah
demo par sa fougue pour porter changé
l'agent toute la raho en tapant la jambe
au pays
[Musique]
allez 430 est une pratique pas 32 bon
lundi à vous bon lundi en particulier si
vous vous prénommé réunis je vous le
rappelle c'est le prénom du jour pour
l'instant les rémy bonne fête les
caennais seront plus précis tout à
l'heure en attaque sous l'annoncé
l'horoscope du jour tant qu'à faire
bonjour et django les concurrents une
portière radio tu y es tu essaies pierji
d'un jour qui m'a dit jean-claude
j'aimerais que tu puisse discuter avec
albert guetta radio antilles alors j'ai
pris mon téléphone j'ai appelé albert et
puis j'ai expliqué albert le type de
radio qu'on voulait faire mais j'ai
senti tellement qu'il a déjà ce type de
radio que à la fin de l'entretien j'ai
lié à l'eau mais on est d'accord tu
viens quand et c'est là où albert est
venu à la martinique parce que j'ai
senti qu albert avait besoin de liberté
pouvoir s'exprimer et je crois que c'est
ce qui a permis à albert d'exploser
c'est quand on lui a donné un micro et
deux platines
il a dit à présent m'en parlait
paniproblème moment est aussi artiste
veut le la rampe de lancement
véritablement albert pas celle là où il
a explosé c'est là où il a fait ses
frasques c'est là où il a hélas il a
émerveillé les gens et même ses
collègues doivent nous émerveiller on
était devant lui comme des garçons de
gamins des gamins je me souviens d'une
fois en réunion ii de programmes en
clair de bord il lui a dit
bon almere tout apprendre la tranche 18
21 heures à partir de 18 heures c'est
bon les gens sont du travail j'en
vendrais de mashable par un magistrat de
la veille à la fin de la réunion il nous
avait sorti le contenu de l'émission et
le titre de l'émission était une boîte à
vitesses nous avons besoin de vitamines
ou braque à vitesse ce but on voit la
fuite et est parti là dedans la halle b
avait un avantage c'est que albert était
présent partout sur le terrain et je
crois que six aussi la force d'un
animateur cd présents sur le terrain
d'être à l'écouté des gens il était à
l'écouté des gens il savait ce que les
gens voulaient et je crois que celle où
les héros les animateurs font
quelquefois des erreurs c'est de rester
dans le studio
albert lui il était bien sur le terrain
et là il avait le pouls de la population
il avait il avait le sentiment de tout
ce qu'il voulait je me souviens fin pour
heures comme ça pour l'anecdote d'un
jour où on arrive dans une commune du
nord très très en retard nous n'avons
pas tous les cadeaux qu'on avait promis
et c est sur le podium je prends des
podiums pourtant fin je prends tout ce
qui traîne et je suis en pleurs en
larmes et je ne veux absolument pas
assuré le direct et albert dit non c'est
ça se passe pas comme ça tu en prendra
d'autres des coudes yaourt
vas-y soeur vas-y nate se tenait vasys
monte et vas-y souris leurs et ils te
sourit rond et ça a marché ça a
fonctionné
ça a fonctionné
[Musique]
cette période de transition la à lui a
permis également de ceux de choses
pouvait il a dû très certainement à
partir de là commence à bien se
retrouver dans un milieu qu'il avait la
docteure mais il resta et tout ça et il
sait où ils sont nés beaucoup imprégné
c'est là à ce moment là mon avis est
qu'il est bien entrée dans nba étaient
toujours à la recherche de la
spiritualité très jeune bon je ne vais
pas dire tout ce qu'il a fait enfin il a
été très jeune à la recherche de la
spiritualité
albert dès qu'il est arrivé chez nous
aux antilles il avait des groupes qui
l'aimaient beaucoup assouan sur le rhum
et bob marley tout de suite très jeune
donc il a d'abord cherché d'un côté la
spiritualité l'a pas trouvé il est lisse
et il s'est tourné vers justement cette
spiritualité rasta et c'est vrai que ça
lui a certainement un nouveau coup
[Musique]
avant il y avait toute mauvaise
propagande sur le mouvement rasta
je pense à travers salle belle date un
gros travail pour le mouvement rasta il
a appuyé les gens à accepter les gens
n'ont pas les cheveux tout ça et par le
travail par par leur talent
quand j'étais jeune on vous appelle
parce qu'il y avait une forte de la
tunique et goûter à la sauce à spag nice
mais nous nous y avait deux parties qui
cherchent et qui s'appelait sur les
radio ténus dad
et puis un jour dominique ne tient qu'un
qui parle créole et qui se dit merde et
puis toi tu ne comprends pas bien
l'anglais puis tu te dis qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui donnait tout en créole
donc et puis dieu là c'est celui qui a
il a suscité beaucoup de vocations de
redonner confiance et une partie de la
population qui n'était pas intellectuel
gauche hispanisants che guevara cuba
mais qui avait autre chose et que nous
on gagne de nous rapprocher d'eux des
black panther de jeff davis des gens
comme bob marley squillaci c'est cet
aspect culturel la réponse à albert
t'as pas lu que l'édiction que nous même
si quoi nous la perle retrouvée la
retenue si la squale dell va faire donc
bibal de respect on est tous des hommes
à l'image de dieu ça le rsa c'est des
choix personnels quoi donc albert ville
a réussi à manifester ça et c'est
merveilleux quoi ils mettaient pas sa
faune en avançant jeu j'apprécie ça
beaucoup de sa pensée qui n'a jamais
misé à fond en avant c'est quand on se
retrouve entre nous on s'est connus
rastafari dont on va parler de mon
projet j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de donner
des documents albert pour cerner les
toupies sa majesté tout ça mais dans sa
vie de tous les jours ils mettaient pas
sa foi en avant et je trouve ça
merveilleux parce que c'est pas ça qui
est personnel la france
[Musique]
le genre d'émission qui faisait part de
sa totale sur la mode de la marine moi
j'ai les conditions en mode mono à des
gens de tous niveaux
alors lui le langage qu'il avait c'est
savoir parler à tous ces gens là tu vois
tous ces gens là le langage des combats
courageux voyez il ya des langages they
were langage etienne tient tête et c'est
pas le langage qu'on parle d'eux les
bureaux du conseil général les bureaux
par-ci par-là belletti côté sophistiqué
il connaissait tous ces langages là mais
comme la majorité du peuple par le
peuple et majorité ont formulé bon pays
a pris majoritaire qui les intellectuels
comme depuis sa toile cette porte et
d'antennes là avec la manière de trouver
qui nous n'avons pas les barbes temps là
parce que conduire à ces gens là vivent
ils la bonne journée à guignol avec un
joyeux anniversaire à la clé c'est de
là-bas de suzy évidemment c'est un code
guignols se reconnaîtra ses piques aux
jambes et avoir le courage un petit
coucou à christian christian tv aqui de
ce tremplin plein bonheur et à qui nous
disons surtout la santé vieux fred
chaumet français puis courage
là vraiment le bon ça m'a bourré
d'erreurs humaines
revenons à mon égard c'est magique a
notamment dit mon but obligeait les
vendre abonnements pour obliger lévy
beaulieu la wii de vous voir vous bouffe
en double droit rombach avez vu je ne
rabats sur tout mais en dix jours sur le
rabat les bords les marchés monétaires
on touche à la vie qu'après tout comme
sept maris sable ni voiture sept maris
des bio dit marie-thérèse madame rouge
avec jodie ça bougeait bossasso
messieurs michel lavoie cours il a béni
va là où niveau rend illégaux a dit rich
aucoin son mac rio c'est comme ça où sa
folie albin louchard ces contrats-là
décalés ou savent les mots à la mode va
passer à l'hommage à l'abbé pierre tout
ça on ne s'arrache et m'ont dit ça ne
mange pas manger nabot place la miss a
bon placement mauve et blanc
abon place et si ça permet de passer
sabam utilisant salon de l'art dans
l'infiniti ne sera à 7 heures du matin
sous terre le journal local et régional
le temps de faire des câlins et des
bisous à colette kitty comment ça va du
doubs a des rides un pont un bien
et puis faut pas raisonner
là c'était beaumont bonjour bonjour
nouvelles ou bonjean s'enfoncer big
ouvrage aussi nous quand j'étais en
bonne semaine ben oui il ya bien sûr le
tout jeune
à moins que je voulais tous les jours
est monté à bitche est ouvert a dû à des
4 et matteo montaguti publicité a battu
par son empathie mais c'est pas ça
on va parler
[Musique]
m
d'autres
[Musique]
2 le matin c'est kate matin jusqu'à 8
heures mais si on m'attaque à albé
occupe bien normal d'arriver à zéro en
86 il a commencé à travailler
l'après-midi avec sylvie et tout de
suite il est passé sur les matinales et
ça a été un carton pour lui les gens
l'ont adopté tout de suite et c'était
albert c'était albert sinon il est je me
rappelle quand j'étais à la technique
chaque fois qu albert était absent il
avait peut-être deux jours de congé on
était assailli par des appels ou et
albert ou albert wahlberg c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours eu beaucoup
d'idées une grande disponibilité et
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a eu du mal à le
suivre parce qu'il s'amenait dans tous
les sens avec lui si je crois que le
public martiniquais s'est pas trompé là
dessus parce que quel que soit le média
sur lequel travaillait le public le
suivait tandis que ce soit une dotation
initiale bien au point la ligne peu
importe quel support il exerçait son
talent
c'est très agréable de discuter avec lui
parce que il était éclectique il aimait
avoir point de vue sur tout et voulait
un an je me rappelle il voulait faire
les émissions de littérature de
démission est connue bref il voulait
tout faire et c'est vrai que c'est un
garçon de cet acabit là il a inc il a
fait une grande ouverture d'esprit
c'est à dire qu'il représente pour moi
le
le professionnalisme telle qu'on a
toujours connu c'est à dire un animateur
qui arrivent le matin tôt en ce sens il
est courageux d'ailleurs de pouvoir se
lever tous les jours à 3h du matin c'est
pas donné à tout le monde et de se
diriger à la rédaction chercher de
nouvelles chercher des informations et
d'en donner aussi aux journalistes qui
étaient là et c'est ça qui est important
pour moi c'est un professionnalisme
profond comme com comment reconnu à
l'époque
[Musique]
une chose qu'il faut retenir d'albert
c'est sa générosité
un homme extrêmement généreux très
cultivé très très cultivé une forme
d'intelligence rare est vraiment
généreux
albert et tenir manceau quoi ça on
l'emmène donc adl berger qu'avant moi
tout croissant il préfère ne pas manger
lui et me donner ça c'est albert mais
moi j'ai un souvenir impérissable avec
albert albert ne serrez pas là miles
choqué et la main comme ça un jour à la
radio il a appris le décès de ma maman
et ce jour là on ne sait pas de choquer
la main il m'a pris dans ses bras et
embrassé ce qui m'a surpris et il m'a
dit à l'oreille plus fort sarrias avec
sa boîte et ça je ne l'oublierai jamais
[Musique]
albert a été quelqu'un de fantastique
puisqu'il m'a épaulé gt gt gt jeune
joueur 20 23 24 ans et je me rappelle
que les pros premier podium que j'ai pu
faire en martinique devant deux ou trois
mille personnes s'étaient vraiment les
podiums radio bleue les podiums radio
bleue avec avec albert le vendredi le
samedi le dimanche et c'est lui vraiment
qui m'a qui m'a permis de m'exprimer
devant devant une population et de
lâcher mes cheveux comme certains diront
et d'être beaucoup plus à l'aise et en
tout cas d'apprendre cette interactivité
qui avait avec le public à l'époque
parce que j'étais complètement coincé et
ça je lui dois ça évidemment s'il ya
bien une chose parmi toutes les choses
qui nous a apporté en radio depuis des
années
s'il ya une chose dont je me sers
aujourd'hui depuis déjà plusieurs années
encore plus maintenant
depuis ces derniers mois
c'est le quoi qu'il arrive à l'antenne
voilà c'est à dire que quoi qu'il arrive
quand j'allais d'un micro à 11 heures il
faut que je sois un petit soleil pour
tout le monde et c'est vraiment je pense
qu'une des choses principales qui l'a
laissée aux animateurs à lyon ça olivier
auprès d'avon ramage et la nuit est un
petit peu courte je sais en plus il
pleut actuellement dans raison de plus
pour que vous êtes un petit pôle volumes
du transit ce temps ça va travailler
tranquillement gentiment et après je
vous parlais de serey die qui nous
attend super bowl année
[Musique]
e
il dit tout
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
e
m
le genre de moment pas d'avis pas d'amis
personne n'ose même pas vraiment au
moderne la plus grande discrétion c'est
très bien et puis j'ai rejoint di admise
a failli ton papa et durablement
[Musique]